siamo ritornati borgaro e ama del padre
siamo tornati su survive io era il
prodotto ha giocato è stato bellissimo
speriamo sia altrettanto belogi coin già
ma non chiamiamo cpd by chiamiamoci oggi
i vincoli speriamo davvero introduco per
chi non lo conoscesse il nome non mi
ricordo di tasse ok come posso spiegarle
tipo ti pago il gioco con la effe
famosissimo batterlo ial come che si
chiama ora quel mi ricordo quello solo
che si vede dall'alto
questa è la prima differenza è la
seconda differenza è che io sono
fortissimo cosa che nell'altro non sono
tipo di adesso 4 naturale granate gli
altri hanno le armi e io gli farò fuori
solo quella granata guarda sono proprio
fortissimo va bene dovrei riuscire ad
arrivare ciao hai visto che sono forte
ammazzato 1 fermo con un pugno ma
comunque ci sono le armi se riuscissi a
trovarle perfetto
magari se riuscissi a trovare anche di
proiettili ma qualcuno mi da dei
proiettili europeo genetico queste cose
ci hanno cose dentro un casco
ciao
oddio aia intanto sei proiettili che
rimbalzano questo cos'ha fatto
ha lasciato un coltello e non mi ricordo
scusami come si fa a parlare con la
gente non vale non valeva l'aspetta
ecco quindi si parlava la gente non mi
sparare ti prego ti prego
c'è un tipo ii
non mi ha sparato è bello perchè così tu
vai amicizia e non me lo ricordavo che
va bene non mi hanno mi ha ucciso per
ringraziando il cristo però devo correre
corri c'è la safe va bene mi sono
salvato tutti hanno armi o no no
quanta gente devo trovare dei proiettili
perfetto questo un proiettile per questo
un fucile
se uscisse dei proiettili per il fucile
aiuto bici non come faccio a curarmi no
no non posso curarmi non ho pure e non
ho neanche armi porco demonia sono quasi
morto ragazzo sopravvivendo non so come
però vabbè
allora non sono mai riuscita a vincere
la partita sto gioco ci hanno dato molto
vicino
se riuscissi a fare vincere stavolta
sarei molto contento magari non mi
sparate
ok ma l'altro ne mancano 13 e della
partita è finita ci sto male io sono
praticamente morto che cammina da un'ora
e mezza prendi d'armi prendi le prendi
prendi gol premio bravo così mi
servirebbe un kit se c hai voglia kit
per curarti no perché faccio un po
schivo figura guarco demonio
la safe 1 minuto contro no non so come
ci si cura le cure le cure non ce le ho
prendi prendi curati come ci si cura
come cisco ecco cosa clicco questo tool
morto vabbè giochiamo di nuovo ci siamo
arrivati vicino alla vittoria ma non
siamo però arrivati ce la faremo
tranquillo anche l'ultima volta sono
andato molto vicino però non ho mai
vinto però io se riusciamo a fare
qualcosa di meglio io sono molto
fiducioso siamo qua
questo esatto centro della safe fai te
è schiatta maledetto 11 andato è il
primo cielo sono già tolto dalle balle
no dov'è finito tutto visto che lo
stanno giocando a nascondino
ok bene 2 a 2 kg il problema che non non
la chiamo molto bene con le mie p5
quindi dovrei riuscire a padroneggiare
meglio le mie armi ciao molto bene c'è
proprio quello che va messo il cuore dei
morto poverino stesso avevano gli
sparava va beh no
porco demonio ha bisogno ucciso da solo
come non ci sono solo ho fatto tre chili
infatti no che scemo mi sono ucciso da
solo perché i proiettili rimbalzavano
porco demonio nota comportamentale i
proiettili rimbalza porca vacca che
sfigato vabbè dai facciamo previsto
gioco non mi può ammazzare nessuno solo
io posso uccidermi tipo chuck norris va
bene o salve ciao io ci ho provato a
fare amicizia non ha creato cosa devo
fare ma scusami
no no no no no no ma no perché perché
con questa sfiga io nella mia vita mi
servirebbe entrare come ha fatto lui e
uscire se non si può entrare bisogna
arrivare alla vittoria
le belle belle e gli zoom servono per
zoomare la mappa quindi se tu li trovi
del tipo come mirino e sono utilissimi
se non fosse che c'è anche il per
quattro anni che ha per 4 vede ancora
più zoomato quindi ancora più
avvantaggiato è fighissimo sto gioco
l'importante è vincere comunque non
partecipare eccolo lì lo zio
madonna esploso come ma l'ho ucciso io e
devi morire però anche loro ci sono
altre su quest'altro cielo e lucido io
ci provo mi ha posto qui esce dai
mannaia quanto tempo uscire ecco come mi
sono mosso come mi sono mosso quello
uscito come mi sono mosso come mi sono
mosso quello è uscito aspettato un'ora
come mi sono mosso è uscito devi morire
morire non è possibile lega non è
possibile ve lo giuro un giorno farò
piazza pulita di sta gente no vedo
spesso amici siamo amici siamo vicini
siamo amici quello da non ami ami colore
medico ok ok perfetti city city canicani
tranquilli lo chiamo tutti lottiamo
tutti bene bene bene ok però c'è un
sacco di gente che non riconoscano tutti
qua che ci picchiamo aiuto aspetti
aspetti aspetti siamo amici siamo amici
siano amici incontra cosa vedo lì forse
come la cassa lì che la ferma devo
capire cos'è sta roba o gesù cristo
mi sa che cosa faccio una piazza pulita
io 1 2 e 3 anche miss a nolo mancato che
idiota
ok ho rischiato per un attimo e regalo
rischiato tantissimo mentre chi dai
buono che stai partita bene oggi vinco
io
non è un nome a caso ragazzi let's go my
friends allora l'elmo livello 3 armatura
livello uno zaino livello 1 no ho
sbagliato singer
vabbè da meno sa aperta così sta roba è
un coltello stranissimo penso che levi
un sacco immagino penso che juan sciotti
non ne sono sicurissimo però penso con
sciotti ciao mamma mia quanto rischiato
quanto rischiato da quel che aveva
sparato prima vabbè non ho band e il che
è una cagata mi servono assolutamente
band band e ti prego mannaia la morte
qua c'è gente si no ti prego non mi
uccidere non mi ha visto e orbo è scemo
non ha visto mai che culo
chiudi tutto chiudi band e vende vende
curati mamma mia che com'è andata
benissimo
sono amico se nomi cosa amico amico
vieni vieni ieri il suo amico suo amico
ma ti faccio niente giuro giuro per me
sta andando a prendere le armi per poi
uccidermi quindi me ne vado e meglio mi
sono curato però ovviamente non ti puoi
curare tutto serve il kit medico legale
mancano 10 sono tra i migliori dieci
perfetto
sarà un pò un casino quello non mi aveva
visto che ruba fermo non aveva visto
assolutamente poverino non mi da gente
non mi vede solo ninja
chi sa quante minchia di granate c'erano
pezzi che aiuto c'è il per 86 per otto
lo devo prendere non ci credo ma hanno
accerchiato li mortacci loro a che palle
e vabbè adesso che fate spiegami ha
vinto lui lo sapevo alla fine di
ammazzare per forza qualcuno ora che ho
fatto sei killer è stato fighissimo però
arrivare poi alla fine fine fine
difficilissimo
secondo me devo allearmi con qualcuno
raga per arrivare completamente alla
fine però questa è stata la partita
migliore che io abbia mai fatto è 6 kg
sono tantissime
allora benda partiamo subito granata e
se dio vuole un'arma velo sono i corpi
volevo solo i colpi non voglio farti
niente solo colpi ciao nonno sono tra
vico amico amico amico ti prego non ti
sparo è la pena che sfiga centrale
rucola dolce gente ha finalmente un po
di tregua mannaia la morte sono andato
ovunque mi hanno mitragliato ovunque ma
vi pare curiamoci usando delle band non
poi supera il 75 per cento di salute si
ma i kit medici sto gioco sono
introvabili non li trovi neanche per
sbaglio c'è un look impossibile già
trovare un'arma e un miracolo figurati
kit medici non li trovi mai il mio piano
è questo aspetto che passi 1 tanto lo
vedo da lontano che oltre 4 bisogna
valorizzare i propri punti di forza qual
è il mio punto di forza è la distanza
visto che io ho un per quattro non c'è
quasi nessuno e per quattro all'inizio
soprattutto quindi vedo la gente molto
distante questa è questa è una mia
particolarità quindi utilizziamo lo
vediamo se passa qualcuno e poi gli
spari in faccia e ha trovato un
un approvvigionamento nell'acqua ok
proviamoci
se lo prendo bene sennò me ne vado a
giocare a teletubbies no no non pare
miss è ridotta
[Musica]